are you ready for your hosting duties
tonight i'm so ready honestly being the
interviewer is way harder than getting
interviewed you think so yeah it's been
a it's been a process yeah it's kind of
like uh heads up you know that game
heads up where you got to match the face
oh exactly that too so you're just like
whoa it's a lot anyone you're really
pumped to look forward to seeing this
so many people i just want to see jack
harlow that's it that's it yeah not uh
olivia not conor no i mean all my
friends of course but um
do you have a plus one tonight is cole
here with you this evening no no he's
not here tonight well you recently went
instagram official with call correct
um so is it true that it happened that
did he slide into no he didn't slide
into the dms did he say in an interview
that you were a celebrity crush
i know he's one of my brother's friend's
friends so it all like worked out but it
was it was really funny i was like i can
forever hold this to you until the day
you die that i was your celebrity
that's awesome now your fans love
whenever you're hanging speaking of like
the circle of friends that you hang with
coleman with olivia we love seeing you
guys interact on social media but will
there come a point when you guys
collaborate on music together i hope so
i mean i just want to get in the studio
with them and write with them because
they're both incredible all my friends
are so talented they're truly it's so
inspiring to just hang out with them and
be with them so it's fun that's awesome
yeah we're really looking forward to
seeing you on sean mendes's tour of
course the tour got cancelled so have
you heard from sean how he's doing how
his health is holding up i have and uh
yeah he seems great i mean the thing is
is like i i really respect him for
putting his mental health first because
i don't think people do that enough and
so honestly i'm just like as an idol of
mine since i was super young it's a
really cool thing to do
[Music]